لقد حلّقنا للتو في عين
العاصفة الآن على بعد حوالي 800 ميل شرق
ملبورن فلوريدا وأنا أقوم بإعادة وضع
الطائرة على الجانب الشمالي للعودة
إليها ونرى كثيرًا كما
وصفت العاصفة وهي تنتشر.  لقد
قمنا بمهام جوية في هذه
العاصفة منذ ما يقرب من أسبوع الآن، وعندما
بدأنا كان إعصارًا كبيرًا
وسجلات الإنترنت مدى سرعة
الشهادة به ولكنه كان
محليًا نسبيًا في الوقت الحالي كما ذكرت
أن مجال الرياح يتوسع ونحن
على وشك  على بعد مائة ميل على بعد 100 ميل
من عين العاصفة وما
زلنا نرى على مستوى اللعب على ارتفاع 8000 قدم، ما
زلت أرى رياحًا بقوة الإعصار
بعيدة عن العين وهو أمر
مثير للإعجاب
كقائد، سأعرض بعضًا منه  مقطع
فيديو قمت بالتقاطه أثناء تحليقك وسط
الإعصار في اليوم الآخر، حيث كانت
الطائرات ترتد أثناء مرورك
بالعاصفة. أعتقد أن بعضًا من هذا
هو ليلة الأحد، ولكنه يمنح الناس
فكرة عما تراه في الداخل، لا أفعل ذلك.
أعرف كيف تفعل ذلك في كل مرة
يخيفني ذلك، حتى أنظر إلى هذه الصور،
أه فقط عن الاضطراب المرتد
الذي تواجهه أثناء
محاولتك الحصول على البيانات، كيف يمكن
مقارنة هذا بالأعاصير الأخرى التي
مررت بها عبر
الخارج  كان لها
عمر افتراضي أطول مما اعتدت عليه
عادةً، سأقوم بثلاث إلى أربع
مهمات في العاصفة قبل أن تصل إلى
اليابسة في بعض الأحيان ولكن آه كانت هذه العاصفة
فوق الماء لفترة من الوقت
وكما قلت كانت كبيرة  كانت العاصفة
محلية نسبيًا عندما طارنا
فيها لأول مرة وتعرضت لبعض الضربات القوية
التي أخرجت الساقين من
تحت أوراق الشجر أو هناك قليلاً
وكنت داخل العاصفة بينما
انهارت نوعًا ما في أول
مهمتين لي ولكن نحو  في
الليالي القليلة الماضية، أعادت تنشيط نفسها وأعادت ترسيخ
نفسها كإعصار قوي جدًا ومخيف،
وهي الآن
تتجدد ببطء ولكن كما ذكرنا، فإن
مجال الرياح يتوسع وينتشر